did so we're in for quite a treat today
we don't just have one but we have a
whole panel of speakers so as many of
you know we've had a collaboration with
Kaiser Permanente and in particular the
data information and management enhance
management and enhancement group related
to analytics and there was a course we
taught last summer and we'll be offering
it again this summer and we're lucky
enough to have them come in today
several members from the group to speak
about not just what they're doing with
analytics at Kaiser but also some career
opportunities and some ways to think
about that no be a panel so the
interactive piece is of course
encouraged please remember we are live
streaming this so if you do have
questions please remember to hold while
you're asking the question so it's
recorded and more importantly so that
people out in the internets can hear I
will also be monitoring on Twitter and
if you are watching this on livestream
you can send us questions to at ohsu
informatics and the hashtag is demise
conf conf and we will make sure that
your questions get answered great thanks
for having us my name is Allison Schmitt
I lead the development of bi and
analytics team in our department that
really have accountability for data
marts and reporting go ahead and I'll
let my colleagues introduce themselves
I'll kinda have to have pass this around
we're just give me a little hint on the
agenda I'm going to spend about ten
minutes talking about how our
departments structured said roles
responsibilities I see some familiar
faces so if this is repeat from last
time you're here I apologize I'll
highlight some of the open positions we
have keith is going to spend a few
minutes talking about some of the work
efforts that were doing currently to
drive forward improvements efficiency
and quality in our Kaiser permanent in
Northwest region and then we have a
great panel of our analysts that you
know actually do all the great work so
those projects will tie to a lot of the
work that they're doing so you can ask
them both questions about what their
role is like what are we what's our
group like what's Kaiser like but all
more importantly the kind of projects
that were working on Keith will kind of
tea that up too so any questions about
our agenda today
I got a couple of handouts if you
haven't picked them up we can handle it
to you one is the roles grid i'll be
walking us through some of that and in
the seminar that was mentioned we kind
of put a little blurb about that i'm not
sure if these days are exactly correct
so when you go sign up validate the
dates based on the catalog itself but
the description the tenth of the course
is all in alignment so just wanted to
highlight those does anybody need a copy
okay wit of which ones both okay great
thanks all right so hand it off to keep
my name is Keith crowland I'm a
information analyst manager so I have a
team of analysts information analyst
largely which is more our kind of broad
consulting analyst role we work more
closely with the frontline operations on
a whole range of different applications
and so I'm now going to hand it over to
the team right so my name is Sean
flourish under I'm one of those
information analysts that he mentioned
and although we have a broad range I'm
actually focused into areas population
health where we deal with reviewing
chronic conditions weight management in
a lot of cancer care and then the other
half of my role is the regional
telephonic medical center which
basically there the focus area was they
had a data tool that wasn't meeting
their needs and so we work towards the
data tool where we can pull data and get
them accurate review of what all the
work they're doing and they can show the
business that now hi my name is Jin
stone and one of the information analyst
my focus area is clinical quality and
population health so this road goes a
lot of case management disease based and
also medico five-star and there's some a
lot of like patient outrage and
intervention going on and
there's also another area involves
employer group health and wellness so
this is a new strategy in our region
that's a lot of exciting work to do my
name is Lucas k Womack I'm a BSA team
lead I'm actually on the prod support
team it's my main area of focus I helped
build software for Team tool
efficiencies I helped look at new
technologies and in general Emma
technology advocate hi I'm Karen Brooks
and I'm a report analyst within the team
I've worked in various areas of the
group focusing on Hospital surgical
services ambulatory care at one point
and the biggest and finance the biggest
role of the report analyst is to
basically find ways to take all the
information that's out there and
presented in a way that can be
actionable so that's kind of the focus
of that re
think I'm gonna have to hold this so
thank you thanks for having us so these
guys represent three of the four roles
that you'll find on this sheet the role
that we do not have is data analyst I
also lead that team so I could talk
through that with you our dining
department has grown over the years in
size but we actually haven't grown in
FTE so in the northwest Kaiser's is huge
we have 200,000 employees about 11,000
in the northwest region were close to
500,000 members and overall in the
nation were over 10 million members so
we have a huge structure in the
northwest region alone we all sit on the
health plan side which is the ambulatory
care operations nurses mas practitioners
as well as all of our insurance sales
marketing membership all of the support
structures but then we have a permanent
a partnership which is our physicians so
they're kind of the backbone of what we
do because we treat patients but
obviously it's a it's a strong
partnership so over the years dime has
what we've done is we've actually
centralised analyst so we just have
analysts at sat in individual areas and
they work on their own and we've brought
people in from those specific areas into
the broader dime team structure that
helps us get efficiency a process
clarity of work they can collaborate and
share more closely than if they were a
single analyst kind of siloed in one
area it also allows a lot of job
opportunity and growth so we have an
information analyst lead at the hospital
start out on my team as a data analyst
to into a day and analyst three and then
jumped over the information analyst role
so having that kind of consolidated
structure that allows that ability for
team members to move through different
job families too so we support a broad
area of health plan operations you heard
some of them here I mean this is
everything from I need to sign up as a
member to I want to call make a
complaint to I need to make an
appointment to I'm in the appointment
room what are my care gaps to helping
the groups that we support understand
what those care gaps are with their with
their groups themselves wide spectrum so
we probably probably support over 45
different subjects we have over
two thousand users of our products so
kind of a broad spectrum or try to give
you a taste of what that really means in
terms are old today so the sources
business systems analyst Luke is the
lead of the business systems team this
is all about technology and systems and
entry of information so in your world is
applications in our world we also have
epic analysts so everybody entering
information into our health record we
have application coordinators which play
the business systems analyst role but on
our team the business systems analyst
focus on our own tools so our request
process our production ticket issues our
tree we manage hierarchies you know some
of those tools at manage those trees so
a business systems analyst are all about
tools and data entry the next is the
data analyst role this role is really
focused on building data structures they
could be martes they could be a mini
warehouse they could be just a set of
tables that are used for a specific
analysis but the data analysts really
need to understand about how to go get
data from different systems how to
structure that data so that can be used
and consumed for analytics the value we
really bring is trying to bring data
across system so every request we have
may the data from four different systems
so their role is really to help go out
and understand what that data is
normalize it bring it into a structure
that can be used by the other analysts
can I mention report analysts report
analysts take information and create it
so that can be presented we use SAS and
Cognos bi extensively within our team we
have a couple of new tools that are
emerging particularly tableau tableau
has its advantages it has its drawbacks
in terms of drawing on the database but
reporting Alice's variety of tools they
structure graphs charts consumable
information helped prepare self-service
query studios for our end users to use
so that people can go out and
drag-and-drop information so it's kind
of information on demand but yet it's
specific to their needs for one one time
purpose and then finally our largest
group is our information analyst and
this is the area where we used to have
people just starting i think when we
start out with to information analysts
on the dime team we now have over 20 so
these people have subject matter expert
within an area so Sean focus on regional
telephonic medical center June on
population health we have other analysts
that focus on member relations call
center ed so these are people that go
really deep into a subject area they TWP
a lot of the work that goes to the
report analyst and data analyst because
we have less of them so i cant goes deep
in a subject so we've drawn that subject
matter expertise in an area i know one
question that has been really key is
what skills do you look for so so is the
tough question because it not every team
ever is the same and we have a variety
of skills and strengths within our team
but certainly you have a really strong
base and sequel some kind of tool i know
you guys do some are for us with a purse
ass we do have we need database
backgrounds so oracle teradata are two
of our main database types we really
look for people that can take an
ambiguity and dry out draw that into
specific actual information we have a
lot of business owners that aren't
analytical they kind of think they know
what they want to do but they don't
really know so they may come with
requests we've got to guide them through
that to try to really get to what
they're trying to do evolve so there's a
consultative piece to it that goes in
sort of that well-rounded skill set to
be able to talk people through
situations present information brown
trip look for feedback but certainly a
baseline of sequel is important and you
know the healthcare background is really
key but not essential we've got people
from many of other industries that
obviously there's a ramp up of
healthcare but we've been able to kind
of skill up people in that area through
cross training as well so i'm not going
to read this in detail i know for the
people on the web web actually don't
have this that will be posted with this
online but as we go through if you have
questions about this what this means
we've got people in those roles that's
june and sean are both information
analyst loops the BSA karen's the report
analyst i can represent the data analyst
but certainly I think it makes more
sense we start talk about the kind of
projects we do what their role was on
that project probably makes more sense
so any questions before we dive into the
project work and
on the panel questions about the sheet
now it's laid out okay thank you
does that work can you hear me yet okay
good so I'm going to talk through three
projects to kind of really tee up the
panel session to give a little bit
context and it may be within those and
in terms of maybe the answers other
questions and also to give a flavor of
some of the things that we work on these
are bigger or longer-term efforts as
opposed to there's a lot of lower-level
console anglers a lot of ad hoc type
work going on so these are kind of this
isn't necessary representative all the
work but I think are interesting project
so the first one and it's been mentioned
a couple of times is the work that
Sean's been doing with the regional
telephonic medical center and so this is
where we have nurses and doctors
basically giving a treatment and advice
over the phone so we have a nursing vice
line which is a key kind of part of our
whole delivery model as well as the
doctors that are on call for a whole
number of different things but tends to
be taking over management of patients
that are outside our direct system and
maybe repatriating them but managing
that a whole process and so from an
erotic point of view and this would have
been a couple of years back the the
workflows and how they were using health
connect which is the epic system
together with their other systems and we
see this a lot it kind of just evolved
over time it wasn't necessary strategy
to say well how are we going to extract
information on the back end to give that
kind of secondary use for a whole raft
of things that we want to do but ensure
that we've got the right data coy it's
kind of built through a much more ad hoc
process and what tends to happen then is
they want to come and do some studies
that want to look at okay let's build
some metrics maybe because we want to
look at throughput or we want to analyze
things we want to analyze what happens
to these patients after when we find
informations in text fields it's not
recorded in the same place it's not
because recorded consistently so really
we don't have the breath to be able to
go in and try and kind of my
that to fix that deal on the back end so
what happens in this circumstance there
was a project ready to review the whole
front and focuses but what was really
important was involving analysts working
more on the back end to be able to say
how do we want a structural the
workflows how do we want to structuring
the information coming in which is going
to give us the highest quality data
coming out the back so they really had
buy into the metrics and so Sean was
working with the team and I think Tracy
was working before that was really to
how they were configuring the front end
testing the information on the backend
fine-tuning that so that we're going
from a situation where they really
didn't have any reliable metrics and or
information source on the back end
that's certainly within our team we
would want to link with lots of other
parts of the system but be able to do
that in a in a consistent kind of manner
so it's kind of like a day of quality
but it's really sang with filling those
gaps and bringing forward information
and certainly a lot the skills from the
information analyst point of view is
connecting the front and processes with
the information we put on the back end
so into really important knowledge of
the workflows exactly the
decision-making that goes on when the
date has come again is absolutely key
terms of analyzing the information on
the back end you need the technical
skills but there's a client you you can
acquire the technical skills but if you
don't really have the subject matter
expertise to be able to do that and so
if you have questions about that Sean to
man the second project is really came
out of work that June was doing choosing
my team at the time around in the
population health area this was an area
where there was growing demands within
the organization to do a lot more
because in Kaiser with our integrated
system we have a very rich set of data
on our members everything that happens
to them pretty much within the
healthcare environment we can map what
we can map that through their health
record number and so when we're looking
at managing populations rather than
match sort of managing the process and
efficiency side of health care great
opportunity to find those more complex
patients or to go in and do disease
management and diabetics or whatever it
is to be able to understand all those
different pieces
a growing area huge demand but from
efficiencies point of view lots of or
maybe a series of ad hoc analyses and
saying we know we need to probably try
and build more of an infrastructure here
to support this type of work and it was
kind of two ways of looking at it so if
you think about we've got say we're
roughly half a million members and I
think that was up to 125 different
metrics so these are you could be
utilization but could also be disease
markers lots of different things but
it's more like a picture of a patient
you know are on a record and being able
to use that to drill down and define
subpopulations to do outreach and really
work with the clinical quality folks but
also measuring clinical quality at the
group level so this is the employee
group level so it's the same underlying
data but we want to use it one to
actually go out manage patients directly
but also to monitor a lot that a lot
tend to be that those quality measures
for those groups and out of that came a
project which we call project tree house
and like Tyler show where they came from
or what it's supposed to mean but it was
a cross-functional effort and this was
interesting for our team because it was
dimed him as a whole a different way of
approaching it we tried to do a kind of
rapid week development we made a lot of
progress in there we didn't quite get
exactly where we wanted to be but I
think we covered a lot of ground and
June was really the more the
forward-facing with the customers and
Luke was heavily involved as well from a
technology point of view in saying if we
this is the structure of the day or what
kind of technology solutions can we use
to actually analyze and work with that
data so that's the second project we're
doing pretty good and then the last one
was a is more of a kind of finance type
focus but has analytics going kind of
right down to a very detailed level
which is it's really kind of
productivity we also call it unit of
service flex budgeting so this is the
idea of and the work that started was
the cameras involved the project I was
involved with a project for a hospital
system using external benchmarks which
really
measuring volume throughputs of
departments so it can be for a nursing
unit it's going to be like equivalent
patient days it was the EVs folks and
there's going to be pounds of laundry
whatever it is but it's a way of saying
we have loads of data but how do we
really focus managing our departments so
one is in terms of getting accurate
measurements of those being able to use
benchmarking external benchmarking
information that really says where how
we doing are we good bad or indifferent
but then having that information used an
irregular reporting cycle to really
drive change within those groups big
project it was kind of similar things
have been tried before but I think one
of the unique things that we bought was
really trying to separate parts of the
process out so on the finance side where
the date was very stable and we already
had bi type reporting solutions we
wanted to really use and leverage that
infrastructure we were in place but what
we found was when you've got to go to
every single Department across and
ideally than going to do it across the
whole system and come up with a measure
for output so you're working with
respiratory therapists at the hospital
and you're trying to come up with a
definition of what they do and
summarizing it down to one number it's
huge challenges there on the business
rule side and so what we found is you
need much more flexibility on the
business rules side where the finite
state is much more structured so we had
this idea of what we called above the
line below the line so the above the
line is the information analysts working
very closely with the operations to
really come down and come up with all
those different volume metrics and a lot
of this is coming out of epic
essentially on the back end but then
working on a process where we can marry
that up with the the kind of
industrial-strength reporting and
structure that we have already with our
finance data but using the same tools in
terms of Cognos to take out self-service
tools so that's a really exciting lots
of different things and for Kaiser the
fact that it's using external benchmarks
and a way of measuring our business
started in the northwest it's now been
adopted in California something within
the hospital but long term is a strategy
for basically day-to-day management of
resources with it within the
organization really exciting analytical
project
I want to end it there so I'm now going
to pass it over to these guys if you
have any other more questions about any
of those examples but we can deal with
that through through the panel but
without further ado I guess I'll hand it
over to you I hand up to you guys in
terms of Q&A
I'll start with an easy one out what is
cognis I'm not tonight Karen do you want
to do you have this oh sorry sorry at
home people huh is this on yeah so um
light on yes nobody home all right so am
i doing yeah okay so cognos is one bi
tool or business intelligence tool
there's a lot of tools out there you may
have heard of business objects or
crystal or SAS or there's a lot of
different ones right so cognos is one
that's an enterprise solution kind of a
counterpart to Business Objects if you
know that and it's a tool that allows us
to develop and present reporting within
a web environment so it has tools within
the Cognos application that allow you to
develop those reports and then the
Cognos web application allows them to
present out the reports so that end
users can go in there and click and run
a report and have prompts and that kind
of things it also allows you to
multidimensional eyes your data so it
handles multi dimensional models
I was wondering if you can just come
through I can't tell anyway could you
say a little bit more about the data
normalization like what types of
problems are you trying to solve with
data mobilization also what type of
techniques and what types of compromises
are you making like some of the problems
you typically run into so I'll I I'll
address this one because it's a it's a
great question that's never easy so we
have 56 plus source systems in the
northwest region alone so our member
where our sales pipeline is captured is
different than where our membership data
is captured then is different than where
our complaints are captured which is
separate than our 20-plus modules of
epic in all of these our challenge is
always how do you link data between
systems and every question we get is not
siloed to one area so we'll get a
question like what members that have had
a legging referral ended up in the ed at
an outside hospital and so that requires
us to go to the claim system the
membership system the referral system
both ed specific reports so we have to
tie together five different types of
systems and data in that situation to be
able to answer that question it's a fair
business question but to be able to
answer it we've got to tie that data
together so in organization we have
memory code number and health record
number and they're not how they're
structured and every one of those
systems is different so we don't have
this world-class architecture that
starts from the core that actually says
okay every system is going to have
member and is going to have this
structure for remember then that's how
you link it up so whenever we have a
project we have to figure out how we
link that encounter or that specific
bill or that specific person between
those so the techniques we use first
we're going to find it and then we have
to do you know testing structuring
probably a most robust system we have a
star schema dimensional model so
we used we used common dimensions so
we'll have a patient dimension while the
provider dimension will have a location
dimensional of a date dimension and so
every fact and facts are the amounts are
counts 0 number of visits number of labs
number of dollars those are all facts
anything that's an amount or count but
then we try to make all of those
dimensions common because those are the
things that tie together so the question
will always change what was the number
of ED visits what was the dollar of that
ed visit so it was a little you know was
location so all those by location by
provider by referral those are all
become the dimensions so we try to
structure those similarly so that the
facts that are built in the middle can
be reused to those dimensional
structures so that's one technique we
use some routes brute force you know hey
does anybody know anything about this
can you come help me do it certainly
we're trying to do more enterprise wide
as a kaiser to try to do a lot of that
structuring so we have a movement right
and loud more to enterprise data marts
or warehouses where we used to just have
a membership set up tables from
membership of the Northwest made a set
of tables on claims for the Northwest
now we have a claims data warehouse so
at the national level all claims for the
entire company are going into claims
data warehouse all Member records are
going to the membership data warehouse
but those are so siloed but it's better
because at least as a structure so every
region's not doing membership
structuring on its own we now have a
place to go get it but it's still not
that cross-functional question that ties
back to the day the question so a lot of
different techniques depending what
we're trying to solve you know if it's a
data quality problem or a formatting or
you know that can get in a lot of detail
about in general that's kind of
strategies were employing to take it and
it's your question okay I'm skinny press
the button do you use heuristics also
heuristics you can you tell me more
about her what heuristics is you is the
data
yeah we have that we have that probably
more in some of the more advanced
information analyst spaces but most of
the data Mart or the data normalization
was talking about is more about the data
as it exists but certainly we've had
some like other places where we've had
those more advanced techniques or text
mining projects to try to take and
drought what do that one of those words
mean and quantifiable so we've had some
projects around that I'm not sure if
that answers your question but yeah I
was going to confirm we use we use
heuristics at Kaiser they just don't
call it that officially but they do that
there are built-in features into SAS
that helped with some of those text
mining things and they are precisely
using heuristics and some of those
functions is having a range of different
analysts and approaches is really
important in a place like Kaiser because
a lot of the systems were not there is
no ground plan on the architecture we
try and do stuff so understanding where
it's good to be flexible and where it's
good not to be and where you need to we
deal with this on every single project
and there's elements I think of all of
it and how because the least for the
most flexible is an analyst working on
an ad hoc they work with a customer they
have a need they'll go and they'll
extract information they'll do something
with it and deliver it and that's
probably the kind of the sharp end of
the if we have a pipeline but as we move
back that could turn that into something
they want more regularly and as other
people want to do it so we would collect
more information and ultimately the back
end it may be that it ends up being a
full self-service cognos product that
might take us five years to get through
that and each time we're ready kind of
weighing up the costs against what it's
going to take what the value is to say
is this really big enough and we get a
lot more demand that we can deal with so
there's a lot nose in the system as a
lot of
requests for stuff so managing through
that process is really kind of important
and we we tried things and went down
various avenues and found that it didn't
work for whatever because it wasn't the
right mix whatever we needed but that
dealing with that it's not is really
important in terms of something we do on
a daily basis trying to kind of just way
up what's a good appropriate solution
around a scope for a particular need so
as a more of a general response do you
I've done some work with Kaiser center
for health research HR & D do you
interact with them are your data marts
and tools available to see HR and do
they utilize them to answer the research
questions and vice versa if if they've
got things that they're developing to
answer specific research questions is
that something that your team would have
availability to or are they pretty
siloed I'll give a general comment and
I'll maybe pass to these these guys so
clearly they're sourcing from the same
systems as a cue key differences chr is
the whole program by that we mean all
Keiser regions we're just the northwest
the the timeliness of the information
the needs are different so chrs there is
going to be more out date but they have
probably more rigorous processes or
around some of the aspects of the data
they're collecting so the underlying
source data is the same but if we're
refreshing next day they're refreshing
and their needs are not necessarily to
have information coming next day they
just updated monthly or quarterly for
studies and things but the analysts
working there and we do have movement
with analysts between the kind of more
operational side and chr certainly when
we get down to the what we would call
business rules which is more
understanding the rules you need to
apply to the underlying source systems
to actually come up with those metrics a
lot that has to do with understanding
how the information is entered on the
kind of front-end there is certainly
cross sharing of ideas there and the
community more broadly there is overlap
but I'm going to give it to the analyst
to give maybe some more specific or you
have one here yes so actually with the
Cancer Care oversight that I've been
working analytically CH hours actually
come in and also through the other
analytical support on that actually and
so we've been building more and more
collaboration between teams and we do
send data back and forth are actually
partnering to develop a lot of these
metrics for each of these I mean we have
basically work with cancer task force
for almost every cancer that we're
working through in terms of how to make
this more timely and how to get better
care to the patients and reviewing the
whole process top to bottom and CH is
along for the ride and so I'm actually
in touch with them a lot I'll add to
that for a clinical quality side we also
collaborates HR they do a lot of impact
evaluations for us for disease based
case management like a diabetes case
management whether the intervention is
effective or not to the patient whether
we bring down there a1c value or not so
they do some evaluations for us in terms
of the clinical quality part they also
involved there's some I think they
develop some risk scores for the members
to predict who are in risk of or certain
disease and that's one of other analysts
it's actually helping CHR bring that
model into the operational side so they
that they are actually nurses and
pharmacists in using that score to see
who are at risk for certain diseases and
that's really helpful so there's more
and more collaboration between CHR and
operational side of the work in Kaiser
this might be a question for you both
based on what you just said or it could
be the whole panel but we've been having
a seminar that's focused on electronic
health records and genomic data in terms
of precision medicine and I'm thinking
about the cancer clinical care and the
clinical oncology pieces how often are
you if at all leveraging either in risk
calculations or in trying to answer
questions either genomic assays that
might be done and this could be
something just like Baraka or any
genetic information I'm not sure about
genetic information but I know like in
other regions of kinder they do use
genetic information to do a lot of
research not in California do a lot of
research I'm not sure this region and
that could be something maybe to them at
CHR and they do as a specific in the
type of those types of specific
questions are more likely to be with chr
or I guess potentially the California's
we just going to have the resources and
we'll focus is a little bit more
operational but certainly the the model
look I talked about earlier in terms of
the cohort call that there if we have
some kind of genomic marker that we
could add in that it would could be used
on the operational side that would
potentially be how they be organization
would go out and do it but it would be
okay do we find this where can we find
this information yeah we've got a data
source yeah we can kind of plumb it into
the what we're working with and it will
allow us then to use that as one of the
criteria in terms of going and driving
more of the care delivery side of that
row of research side it's going to be
more of a research park question which
is the whole resourcing a model our
operational model isn't really
structured around that it's much more a
little bit more tactical although you
could argue that there's a lot of things
that we'd love to know just from the
data in terms of quality of care you
know hair payee information that are
strictly just pure antal it could be
business analytics more obvious in terms
of the assay so it doesn t much be the
result but it just be are these being
ordered routinely those types of
absolutely and those can be the types of
things and really that's
sorry I'm Doggett yeah we we
periodically have questions on things
just like that of looking I know in the
surgical services side often they're
looking at what was ordered for the
surgery both from a maybe a consistency
perspective to make sure that we're
being covered on all bases with each
operation that happens but maybe on a
cost level or efficiency level of some
kind so they they do look at information
like that to try to improve either the
quality of care or the cost of the care
or maybe even where we're doing the care
and how that affects our patient
availability to the service or the cost
of doing that to lower the cost of our
patients one more because these are all
related the things we're talking about
done so we struggle a lot across the
board and how we represent and present
uncertainty and so there are aspects of
the data that are very trustworthy and
there are aspects that are not and I'm
curious if the strategy is more you know
cut and run in terms of just presenting
that did it's the most confident or if
you are presenting data in which the
temporal piece that you mentioned tells
really nicely into this how do you
handle that and I realize this might
change depending on who the client or
customer is but I'm just curious about
general strategies I'll i think i'll
take that person and i'd like to d'info
up on it she's probably close to this if
it's about quality of the patient care
administering a drug administrative
procedure we absolutely have to be one
hundred percent on that information if
it's about directionally correct with
operations or you know financial trends
or performance trends we talked Keith
natok what's good enough right so I
think that that you know claims data for
us is also three months leggs there's
three up to three months to pay a claim
so anything done outside of our walls
certainly were like well a clip what's
representing the claim bill is not this
is represented in our electronic medical
record internally so there's a
difference there but if it's you know I
think the closer you get to that
spectrum of delivering something to a
patient the closer you get to has to be
a hundred percent if it if it's you know
and it also depends on the type of
request that request is like I wonder
how we're doing with orders okay what do
you want to how many orders are done
kind of a location by a physician okay
here's your first cut right if that
request turns into oh hey we're going to
start basing physician compensation on
how many are actually presenting the
order patterns okay now we have to be a
little more specific because now we're
basing physician performance metrics and
payment on so it kind of depends on the
nature of the quest and the focus of it
but certainly I think there's a spectrum
between it's directionally correct it's
good enough ad hoc and then the other
end of someone's life safety end of it
too so that's how I'd answer but June
might have she's close I just added more
a little bit about clinical quality part
i do pull a lot of data for our
prevention team to outreach patients so
they do need very like accurate data to
speak to the members what they do what
we do is I quoted Ada and then I
personally sometimes check checking the
front end of the data if they are
accurate or not just randomly check and
then the MAS before they are reach to
the patient's they also go up there
electronic records and double-check and
before they are reach to the patient
they study their medical records early
in identified care gaps and intervention
that needs to be done so that's has been
so far been really good so I saw a
general comment this kind of goes back
to the heuristics question in that
sometimes depends upon how you got your
data or how you got to the conclusion
you know if it's a matter of confidence
and fuzziness you know what decision are
you willing to make on that type of data
so we have all types of data in dime
that we work with so I think on a
case-by-case basis you
don't want to look at what type of data
is this it if you're looking at her
istics it's only going to be as good as
your model so maybe i blatantly missed
variable in my model and i think i'm
really confident and I could say hey
we're 100 or 99 or whatever the number
is we got to be careful there and that
I've just add with business partners my
view is always the day of all the day is
wrong it's just a matter of degree
because it and it's we don't get one
hundred percent accuracy anywhere so and
the rellos is that is Allison said it
really depends on the question you're
asking having said that certainly what
we're trying to do and it really helps
having analysts covering different parts
of that the organization is certainly
when we go in on the information analyst
site to begin with we do want to get to
a point and I think the rtm see examples
a great one with Sean which is we're
going to do quite a lot of upfront
validation because of the other thing is
there's that with on the other side of
the epic people just assume if it goes
in that we have this magic wand and we
just go into this database that has
questions and we find the answer and
pull the numbers out it instant to
really understand that there's a it's a
real partnership and I think I use the
language a lot of Rhenish your date or
it's not our data so and it's only what
you put into the system and we have to
work together to find a way to get that
information out and I think more
importantly and I think the rtm see is
that and I'll get off my soapbox but a
great example is once we get folks on
the front and to really consider what it
is they want to use as the secondary use
of information in terms of maybe driving
a lot of the other things they want to
do then it gets really powerful because
then we start designing the workflows
ready to allow us much better quality
day or on the back end and that's where
it's like well we don't want five
different ways to do it but that can be
difficult when you're trying to get up
take on using the front end system to
begin with where people don't want to
necessarily change their processes so
this is a balance but I think if you can
close that loop and really have that
partnership exercise it starts those
things it's by no means easy it takes a
huge amount of time
but it's a really really important
probably something related where you do
you have anything going on with like
vital signs data data from the chart
itself like tabular data from either
devices or let's say meds dosage or
dozing which is usually pretty accurate
and things which are acquired from
systems or devices which are pretty much
accurate sources you wanna talk about
some of the range of stuff that's you
have to sure we do have there's pharmacy
data lab data there's dosage and their
units their way of weather is oral
infusion and way of taking and also lab
data from outside external Kaiser and so
there are some part when mas medical
assistant go on-site to the employer
groups they do measure their basic bio
map like metrics like blood pressure and
sometimes they also do a 1c test on the
site so they do have some kind of device
and to use and then they come when they
come back and those data can be synced
into the system so that's is already in
use and operation is that answered your
question sure so what tools are you
using I mean I you using a standard
tools or something different or there's
some apps in the either the iPad or
something I'm not totally sure but I do
know that they do use a pad and there's
some apps to use you mean toes to
ultimate that input the data or Nick
strange actually do like outcomes work
with it to see exactly what the
analytics of that I mean basically
seeing the outcomes and mapping it to
what the source data was and seeing if
doing a
is a better option than doing be or
something like that much higher level
view I think so you're looking at the
plant testing the effectiveness of
interventions probably either
interventions or even protocols or calls
exactly exactly and even things like
patient the acuity of the patient at any
given time from those metrics which you
can get which are pretty precise as far
as like vital signs I'd say which have
very specific that there are so some of
the applications is so one of the
systems that was actually put together
and we've mined the date on the back end
or something called the patient support
tool so this is taking a snapshot of a
whole number of different potentially
lab values but it could be health status
assessments again individual patients
and this is used by primary care doctors
to actually it comes up with an overall
gap score that allows them to actually
manage outreach and how they manage
their panels and so that's updated every
day but it has a lot of that detail in
there I structuring those questions into
more thoughtful and rigorous scientific
assessments of interventions or things
it's probably more likely to be a little
bit more on the CHR side rather than the
operational side we I think it's an area
where we could certainly do a lot better
which is how we assess evidence there's
a lot of demand for day or in Kaiser how
much of that really drives sensible
decision making is a big debate but it's
like if we know what it is we get asked
for a lot of dashboards a lot of metrics
and it's like what are you going to do
differently it's like looking at these
things will not change them but it's a
good start and I think rigor around that
but you get to a certain point then
you've got to dig real down to the
detailed actionable information and say
well what's actually going to change
this and that's certainly some of the
work good that the Jun's very closely
involved with is doing that and it
happens in lots of different areas
and I will just make one other comment
on even out of automated systems there's
still big problems of the day because
there's met today there's other things
there's things you have to take into
just because it comes out of an
automated system don't just assume the
date is good because that can be
dangerous too but yeah there there are
also models field behind the tools to
put to calculate risk score like framing
Henry score is calculated to see if
patient have heart risk and there's also
other lace or calculated based on
certain model to predict the patient
discharge help out of the hospital how
likely they will come back to the
hospital so things like that do you
capture any patient generated data like
patients due home blood pressure
monitoring or blood sugar monitoring or
do you have any plans to try to
integrate that more into the system
patient reporting on what medications
actually use etc that might make the
data a little bit more meaningful good
dancer I I just went to the virtual care
summit for Kaiser recently and there's a
lot of work being done in that area
there's an entire group dedicated and
they're talking about funding and
resourcing I don't know the exact
numbers about how many people are out
there that we service but we have a lot
of equipment out in the field that we
it's on demand wheel if a call comes
into the center we have to send an EMT
or a home health nurse whatever it is
and whatever equipment they might have
we're capturing data we actually have a
live video feed in some cases that we're
working with so there's some very
exciting stuff that Kaiser is committed
to working on in that area I know that's
coming coming down the pipe
along those lines Kaiser has one of the
largest uses of the epic my chart
patient portal none and is integrated
fully with epic in that regard have been
doing patient engagement for much of on
my chart national kaisers releasing the
integrated visit video visits for the
Northwest region right now so the very
near future as a member of Kaiser you
could actually certain types of visits
we're rolling it out little by little
for departments in areas but you'd be
able to actually have a visit with your
doctor online and that's because of the
my chart it comes through to my chart
yeah say um you were talking about one
things that you can do with the data and
that just kind of brings to mind the
question about do you have any kind of a
process that you use to do anything like
functional decomposition of your your
processes to like quantify the
activities that are performed at Kaiser
to perhaps maybe optimize them or reduce
duplication or do you have like a BPM or
do you use bubble or anything like that
yeah there's there's certainly a BPM
method or multiple versions of that I
think that a lot a lot of that there we
pilots in a region and then when their
success they'll roll out in other
regions so we don't do we probably kind
of have an organic interaction with that
as it goes in so like the RTMC work that
there might be the actual application
person changing the application the
upfront in process inputs where there's
variation then Shaun's evolved from our
we need to state on the back end or
secondary users that aren't in that
process but need the same information so
there's a lot of that goes on it I think
we're we're as an organization we're not
consistent and what that technique looks
like but we've got six sigma BPM hope
you know you depending on what works in
a different region Southern Cal ease is
a completely different thing the
northern cal but it seems to work for
both of them but it will well I think as
an organization we're getting better we
have a 11 Kaiser motto now
that when something works somewhere
let's spread it so last year for us we
we did all the financial performance
reporting for Northwest we redeemed the
best in the program so we extended that
to Colorado so Colorado just adopted
what we did straight out of the box
we're adopting now reporting that was
done in California some crystal reports
out of the box functionality we're
bringing that now to the northwest
because it had a model in California
that works so we try to leverage those
processes with an analytics and data and
certainly operations does that too so
there's models RTMC exists in our region
because it was done in southern cal
worked and now every region has an RTMC
focus so it happens but i don't think
our I don't think it was a program
overall we have one method but I think
there's multiple flavors of the same
kind of emphasis what you're talking
about I was you mentioned rapid
development cycle method I think was in
relation to treehouse you talk about
that would problem you're trying to
solve and what's how's that different
than your typical development site I'll
give a general comment and then I'll
hand it over to the this was just an
idea that I guess we it's a big struggle
in Kaiser and another Allison will agree
with this is there's a lot of great
ideas around but you try to turn those
ideas into things that are actually
workable that are achievable in the
context of very limited resources in a
kind of on the margin because we've got
all this other stuff we have to do and
so we've tried different ways of doing
things in terms of saying let's try and
map out the organization and do the real
long-term and then we found you only
need to get a few bits wrong and
actually the maintenance of those things
could be really difficult and so this
was just a more just through the
bureaucracy of the whole thing as just
let's focus it down and see what we can
do in a week and I'll pass over to these
guys but I think it's just it's it's
very complex and it kind of relates to
the last question which is
just create a space where you can make
some progress create some value and move
things forward is kind of the process we
have to use rather than kind of grander
plans on yeah this is how we could do
stuff it just gets choked because of the
for a whole number of different reasons
and that's just the environment we have
to work in I could comment a little bit
too on treehouse one thing was we wanted
to have the option to fail fast so we
didn't want to have a three-month
project or whatever it was in the
standard way that we used to do things
so at first it was kind of said we're
going to have a little hackathon but it
wasn't that but the best way to
characterize it was a rapid death cycle
so there was actually a lot of pre-work
that was done so we were slated to have
a one week of work what it turned out to
be in the Kaiser environment was it a
lot of the work happened before the week
that was a lot need to take place what
we chose to leave in the week was
ambiguous at first and then we found out
whoa we should have actually done a
little bit more before this because we
don't have what we need to be able to do
what we need to do so we learned a lot
through it we got done what we needed to
do and we have continuing work efforts
that came from that that helped because
we failed fast in some areas and
succeeded as well this is new with
testing out this rapid work it's just a
for a group of people can get out of
their normal routine work and just focus
on we actually logged in in my room for
a week and just to be able to focus on
one specific project so it's actually
very a good experience for us to to have
that and likely will have will be used
it for more projects I just wanted to
say also for this kind of rapid thing
one of the key elements as far as I
understood was to pull in
representatives from the business from
the data side from all the aspects so
that when you're having the questions in
that room you're getting a quick
response and turnover in that process
so my question is about tableaus can you
talk a bit about the experience using
tableau in your organization have you
created any dashboards and how do you
integrate those dashboards in your
workflow and also how do you compare the
interactive dashboards with the static
report generated in Cognos and other
crystal reports so what is your
experience with I'll take that on
because we're really just starting
Kaiser has kind of taken on tableau or
the idea of tableau I think it's being
used in a few small pockets we have a
specific project in our department to
answer some of those questions which is
running this year which is where how
does it really sit against things like
SAS and Cognos our existing tools we're
just using it pretty much as a
standalone tool but also seeing we have
kind of tests within that projects and
one of them is to say rather than
analysts spend a lot of time reanalyzing
what i would call analytical data sets
which is if you think about the example
of the population health all of these
different measures of patients then
understanding the data source is
understanding the business rules to be
able to represent those things takes a
lot of work but just reanalyzing that
table and summarizing it analysts can do
but isn't necessary high value work and
so that's part of the reason that
treehouse came about but with that
example one other way that we were going
which is been owners have the resources
to build those things as if we give that
analytical data set to an end user and a
tool like tableau how can is it useful
because as it's sometimes we have kind
of power users that have a very specific
focus they're not great number we can't
necessarily justify building a big
project so that may be a way of doing it
we're also looking at how analysts can
use it as an analytical tool but as an
analyst as opposed to an end user and
what are the benefits there it's a kind
of different thought process certainly
if you're in sat and you've got a code
stuff
mindset to actually saying right now I'm
going to analyze the problem so what is
it these people are trying to do what am
I trying to do how am I trying to create
value so we're exploring how we can
actually do that as well as
visualizations but we may look and say
well look we could set this up in
tableau but we already have cognos and
you know so we could use it as a
prototyping tool as well but that's kind
of early stages I don't think we've done
that much more at the moment and the
quick comment so some of the tension out
there right now that I've seen in
organizations like Kaiser as well with
tableau is a lot of investments been
done in the bi space with dimensionally
modeled data and tableau is a you can
you can create an awesome dashboard that
looks beautiful really quick and it
would be quite impressive to the people
you're delivering it to trying to get
that done on data source that's
eventually modelled will cause some pain
because you're likely going to have to
do a lot of rework that you've already
done and heavily invested in other areas
you can easily put tableau on top of a
relational data set with and utilize all
the work that was done building your
relational data source so there are
other consulting companies out there
that are working on what they call data
connectors from tableau to be able to
try to utilize more of the VI
information that's already done and so
in our case it would be nice if we could
just point to cognos and use it as is
but we can't so for us we've got to do
it as a one-off keith was saying we got
to pick and choose how we use that low
question
yeah I mean we have a we have a level 2
mandala steps in the strategic
leadership meeting up with a
fluorimetric so it's it's already here i
think that the user sophistication so
the subculture but i want to email me
those other you have to deal with
finality comes with it so there's still
this adoption traductor would have to
happen i think that because of so much
information it's not always clear what's
correct or what with the underlying
definition is for someone that makes it
a lot easier
and a lot of that will happen certainly
with information analysts if that
hopefully got a good working
relationship with their business
partners they'll get involved and
engaged but a lot of the time it's just
managing dimana it's slightly
prioritization is a big issue for our
organization we want to do everything
everywhere and so we really feel that
certain because we get a lot more
demands on us then we can deliver us as
part of it is trying to work out what
the bigger themes are linking those
themes together reducing duplication but
also then creating of enough of a space
where we can do some of the more
potentially long-term strategic value
adding work a lot of the more multi very
exploratory type work predictive type
work but certainly as resource managers
it's really tough because it's like you
want all this other stuff and there is
too much information in the organ all
too much data and in the organization
every initiative for once a dashboard
and a slower holds slow down slow down
what is it you're trying to do here and
but I think some of that is just explore
and that's the only way they're not
doing it as just give me a kind of
dashboard and stuff so I think just
generally on the customer side it's
early days we are making but we're a
long way off being an analytically
driven organization so I just wanted to
add sitting in a meeting to run a report
we designer reports that would be used
in a meeting like that to be very
user-friendly a lot of information and
having the business partners involved in
the development of those designs of
those reports so they're very fluent and
running any production all kind of
report in a meeting and because the
questions are coming from them they're
you they're often more knowledgeable
about the selections they want to make
and how they want to see that data
coming out the ad hoc questions in those
meetings really can only be sort of a
collecting of what your ideas and then
running that back through all these
processes we've talked about to get the
data to a place
can't answer the questions or give the
actionable information that they're
looking for so analysts often will sit
in on a conversation where you're trying
to understand what they're trying to
look at but to just pull up information
on the fly when you're in the meeting
there's usually a lot of questions that
need to get answered before you can kind
of pull that data together in the right
way so I don't know if that helps but
there's kind of that and they do
and and that's true a lot of the ideas
of how we put these martes together for
cognos is so that we have sort of one
answer to a question so if we have a
measure in there it's got a definition
we have a definition written down that's
been communicated out to the users so it
is a little more advanced person that's
going to use that sort of drag and drop
to create on the fly reporting but it's
much better than them trying to go out
and attach all these databases together
to get their answer so there's different
levels of sophistication users are at
those different levels to it that's a
great way to summarize the karen i think
the tableau question before related that
because there's ago i can just create
all this stuff but they bring down the
database because their queries are
poorly written they don't know what
they're actually presenting they don't
know how to link up they don't so that
there's danger in that but you know
certainly the appetite is there and so
the more we can structure these
different tiers of these are people that
better will allow them and Cognos bi
self-service so if you have chance look
at it but it's got a lot of
functionality tableau has some of it's
not as slick or easy but certainly we
can kind of stand behind it say we've
structured the data in a way that you
can't really make a mistake and reports
right but you can drill through you can
drill crossed you can you know
techniques fine because they'll built in
the fact that just because you find
something that is right but I think
generally on the education side
consumption of the information that
healthy complex sapere so many question
it's a huge challenge so I think we're
out of time why should I want it if
everyone could join me in thanking the
Kaiser diversity and if you didn't get a
handout they are up front and we will be
posting them for those online on the web
as well and we do multiple positions
open we always seem to have new things
open from people getting promotions or
different roles and our how to find a
job as a set the bottom of the sheet so
take a look at it if you're looking for
a job thank you